حسنًا ، باولا ، لقد كانت عطلة نهاية الأسبوع من عمليات
الإنقاذ الرائعة للأشخاص في
المنطقة الجنوبية الشرقية من تركيا يتم انتشالهم من
تحت الأنقاض لمدة أسبوع تقريبًا
منذ الزلزال المدمر الذي وقع يوم الاثنين ، وتم
إنقاذ هذه المرأة البالغة من العمر 85 عامًا في هاتاي بعد قضاء 152
ساعة في تجويف كان
بالكاد يبلغ عرضه 40 سم وفقًا لشبكة
CNN Turk ، وهنا تم تصوير فريق إنقاذ
يسافر على طول الطريق من لوس أنجلوس وهو
يعمل حتى الليل يوم
السبت لإنقاذ أم وابنها البالغ من العمر 18
عامًا ، ولكن بالطبع مع
استمرار عدد القتلى في صعود الأمل.
تتضاءل بسرعة وبدأت نافذة
البحث عن الناجين تحت الأنقاض في
الإغلاق ، والآن مع بدء التركيز في
التحول من إنقاذ الناجين
إلى انتشال الجثث ، تُرك أولئك الذين تركوا بلا مأوى
ليتصالحوا مع
الدمار الذي يعتمدون عليه الآن كليًا
على إنقاذ الأرواح
المساعدات الإنسانية ، ولكن كان هناك
تدفق هائل للدعم مع التبرعات
الواردة ليس فقط من جميع أنحاء
البلاد ولكن أيضًا على المستوى الدولي ، يجب أن
يقال أنه عبر الحدود في
شمال غرب سوريا ،
أثبتت المساعدة الإنسانية أنها أقل قوة بكثير من
المساعدات الحاسمة فقط مما يجعلها  الطريق إلى
المناطق المتضررة بعد أيام من
وقوع الزلزال ، وبينما كانت المساعدات الإنسانية قد
شقت طريقها أخيرًا عبر معبر بربيرهاور
الحدودي من تركيا ،
يقول بعض المتطوعين إنه ببساطة
متأخر جدًا ، فإن سكان شمال سوريا
بالطبع يعتمدون بشكل كبير على
المساعدة الإنسانية بعد  سنوات من
الحرب الدامية على يد الرئيس
بشار الأسد الآن في سوريا ، هناك
شعور حقيقي بالهجران ، لكن في
تركيا هناك أيضًا شعور
بالإحباط وحتى الغضب لبعض
المطالبين الآن بالمساءلة ،
وبدأت وزارة العدل التركية بالفعل
تحقيقًا  في مزاعم
الإهمال في البناء مع
اعتقال العديد من الأشخاص بالفعل ، لكن البعض
يتساءل الآن عما إذا كانت الحكومة قد بذلت ما يكفي
للاستعداد
لكارثة بهذا الحجم